He was one of the greatest statesman of the 20th century, born a small town,
nobody in the Austrian empire, Tomasz, Garrick masseur.
It can nonetheless wound up rising to the very top of central European politics
and then academic and philosopher.
He made his name defending the rights of the downtrodden from Jews falsely
accused of ritual killings to Slav separatists,
but it would be what he did during world war one that cemented his reputation
part cheque and part Slovak master Rick dead to envision a homelands for both
ethnicities. When the Austro-Hungarian empire disintegrated in 1918,
it was from his blueprints that Czechoslovakia was born. Yes,
master Rick was more than just the founder of the Czech and Slovak Republic.
It's first and longest serving presidents.
He helped steer this brand new nation through one of the darkest times in modern
history. Leading by example, he tried to create a liberal, rational democracy,
amid a sea of dictatorships only to live long enough to see his homelands begin
to crumble before the awesome mite of Nazi Germany,
both their European George Washington and the modern day philosopher King.
This is the story of Tomas Masaryk the father of Czechoslovak.
Yeah.
Cool. March day. When on massive,
Eric was born in 1850 outside of modern day Hodan in,
in the Czech Republic,
both the dad was anything remotely like the Czech Republic in existence.
Back then in the mid 19th century,
central Europe was dominated by the Austrian empire. Under the Habsburgs.
The monarchy had ruled all checks speaking lands for centuries until recently
this has just been the way things were. But two years before master X Beth,
something that happens that would profoundly shape the course of his life.
1848 had been Europe's year of revolution across the continents. off.
Liberals had risen up against Kings and Amber is igniting political fires from
France to Prussia. It's a hungry in Bohemia, the Czech historian,
friends of Shaq Polaski, the ghouls,
a revolutionary Slavic Congress determines to win autonomy for all Slavs in
the Austrian. And Bob,
unfortunately the Austrians had responded by bobbing Prague to bits and well
that's had been that almost the truth was once nationalism was out of its box.
Once those check dreams had been given form, it was impossible to put back in.
It would take another seven decades,
but the hopes of the 1848 revolutionaries would have one day be fulfilled and
it would be all thanks to Thomas.
Masaryk not that there was anything in his child to do indicate the boy would
grow up to be so important.
Master his father was a salt of the earth Slovak Coachman working on an Imperial
estate. Well,
his check mother had a simulators with the dominant Austrian culture.
The family were also relatively poor enough. So the master,
his parents felt they couldn't afford to send their son to secondary education.
It was only thanks to outside intervention that master Derek didn't spend the
rest of his life in obscurity from the earliest stage.
Boy had been a prodigious devour of books.
Like if books were a breakfast buffet,
master Rick would be the huge American in cargo shorts.
Going back for 17th servings of bacon, he had read everything.
He could get his hands on retaining knowledge on hyper obscure subjects.
Eventually the Dean of the local school couldn't take it any longer.
And he went to Mr and Mrs. Masaryk and basically said, guys, I know you're poor,
but you have to give this boy an education. And so it was that young master,
Eric found himself ditching his local locksmith,
apprenticeship and enrolling in Bruno's Catholic grammar school.
The move was a lifesaver at school Masaryk approved. So adept,
he won a scholarship. However, this still wasn't enough to fund his studies.
So he took up tutoring work for the family of Amazon Lemonnier.
The director of the police. This would turn out to be extremely lucky in 1868,
the Catholic raised masseur extorted, refusing confession, not a big deal.
You might think, but the grammar school considered it.
A requirement's when master at kept refusing, they kicked him out.
And just as long as Nash master X time and education could have been over,
had it not been for Lemonnier when the policemen found out about the suspension
and he was pretty much like that's a bit weird. I'm about to move to Vienna,
to become a super important police guy. How about you come with me?
And that's how in 1869,
Tom Masaryk found himself living in the Imperial capital life. Wasn't easy.
Even with Lemonnier as a patron master,
Rick worked his Priddle off tutoring the family and passing his exams,
but pass them. He did enrolling in 1872 at Vienna's philosophical faculty.
This was a huge step for the son of a semi-literate Slovak Coachman,
but it almost all fell apart in 1873,
Lemonnier died and Masaryk was suddenly without a guardian angel.
It was only through sheer luck that he managed to find another wealthy family to
take him in and keep our video from fizzling out right here.
Finally in 1876, mastering graduated.
He moved to Leipzig hoping to do some studying,
but it wouldn't be books that occupied his mind.
It was in Germany that Masaryk met the woman who had changes.
It's compile a list of the most intense periods of master ex life.
The summer of 1877 would certainly have to make the top three that's because
over the space of just two months in Leipzig master Rick met,
fell in love with and got to engage the women that he'd be with for the rest of
his life. Shola Garrick was a wealthy expatriate from New York.
Who's determined. Progressivism was like a grenade dropped into stuffy,
central Europe, a philosopher and feminist. She,
and Masaryk bonded over a love of John Stuart mill,
particularly his landmark essay on the subjugation of women.
You know how you occasionally meet someone.
You feel like you can talk about anything with a person who just gets you well.
That was master Eric and Garrick.
When master Rick Olsen managed to save Garrick from drowning during a river
trip, it was just the sexy icing on the cake of love. And yes,
you can be certain there's. I'm going to use that particular metaphor again,
engaged shortly after the original plan was for both of them go back to their
respective homes. So master, I could find a job,
but when Garrick was taken ill in America,
massive wreck abandoned Vienna to be by her side,
the two married in New York city on March the 15th, 1878,
the early bum note was master at commencing the full power of asking his new
father-in-law for money,
which went over about as well as calling him a stupid yang and kicking him in
the balls.
But when it became clear that master Rick was literally broke dad consented to
keep the new family afloat finances,
semi secure master Rick and Sean had returned to Europe,
but it was three solid years of awkward handouts from dad until Masaryk finally
landed a professorship at Prague university.
The family moved to the great Bahamian city in 1882,
just as everything was changing, the romantic nationalism of 1848,
hadn't gone away in Prague.
Instead as more checks flooded in from the surrounding countryside,
it had reached a fever pitch.
Masaryk joins the university just as it was being divided into separate checking
German institutes. While he did get swept up in the wave of feeling,
writing a treatise on Mr. 1848 himself to shack Polanski.
He wasn't some mindless nationalist in the 1880s.
A key pillar of the Czech revival was a pair of recently rediscovered Epic poems
from the medieval era written in old check,
considered the Bohemian equivalent of the German NEBA Longin lied.
They were a source of intense national pride.
They were also as fake as Dr. Damage of George Washington taking part in
WrestleMania, something massive. Rick proved with some Def literary analysis.
Naturally all the Czech nationalists hated him.
It's here that we see one of the most admirable things about mass Rick.
Although we had his own romantic ideals,
he was a man who believed first and foremost in being rigorous in his beliefs,
even when it made him unpopular. As he supposedly once said,
the glory of a nation cannot be built on counterfeits,
nor is this the only example of master egg being willing to swim against the
tide is later in 1899,
he would publicly agitate for the retrial of Leopold Hills near a Jewish man
convicted on non-existence evidence of ritual murder.
At this time anti-Semitism was rife among Czech nationalists.
When master Rick came out on Hills and aside,
he was pelted with stones and spat on in the street at the university
nationalist check students hounded him until he was forced to go on unpaid
extended leave. It was a high price to pay for his commitment to rationality,
but it did have one unexpected good side.
It would be weathering these storms that gave massive brick,
the steel backbone that it need to soon change the world.
[Inaudible].
One of his periodic controversies that master rig began to turn away from
academia and towards politics. He began writing articles,
agitating for a revival of the dreams of 1848 dreams focused on winning check
autonomy within Austria, Hungary. Not that he only focused on checks.
One of the sharpest articles was a demolition of how the Hungarian,
half of the empire treated Slovak by North Jersey in no time at all.
Master had established himself as a heavyweight check think up.
So when the liberal young checkbox,
he approached him about running in 1991 elections, it seemed like a no brainer.
Masaryk took them up and was duly elected and found himself back in Vienna for
the first time in years,
what he saw that didn't fit him with confidence in Austria, his Reich's rats,
the young shacks hopped on a course of uncritical nationalism,
unwilling to work within the system so much as just shouted it in 1893,
it quit in disgust.
Certain there's a lack of realism was what was keeping the checks from making
any advances for the next couple of years,
he hung around the edges of the Prague political scene,
writing books and churning out articles by 1900 though,
he decided to put his money where his mouth was that yet master Rick founded his
own realist party with the aim of achieving check autonomy in as the name might
imply a realistic way. Although the party wasn't a bust,
it also wasn't a major success or Marsh in 2017.
This was not,
although it's succeeded in returning master acts at the ride strats in 1907,
it was a minor force at best one, among many check parties.
It probably didn't help that the nationalists still couldn't agree on what they
wanted.
Did they want an autonomous province within Austria or a wholly independent
state,
but while master Eric was firmly in the autonomy camp align was soon going to
change master X transformation from realist to well changing.
Visionary began on the 28th of June, 1914 that day,
the radical Bosnian Serbs assassinated the add to the Austrian throne,
triggering a series of crises that quickly led to the gigantic crisis.
That was world war one for years master,
it had been condemning both Austria's meddling in the Balkans and its Alliance
with Germany.
Now he watched in horror as both of these things dragged the entire continent
toward unprecedented bloodshed by Christmas master,
Rick had had enough now convinced of the need for a separate check nation.
He had it off and to voluntary exile that the ancient cities of Europe on fire
master record began a PR drive designed to make the allies recognized,
check independence. It was an insane task master.
Eric had friends in academia across the worlds, but he wasn't exactly famous.
He was master of the lonely guy,
timidly knocking at the doors of power with a pretty crazy request. Well,
maybe lonely is a bit unfair in 1915 while in France,
Masaryk was joined by another future president of Czechoslovakia at VOD
Benish together bands with the help of master ex literary friends,
they managed to get themselves before the online leaders long enough to be
officially recognized as the check liberation movement.
It was an important first step and acknowledgements that they weren't just two
random dudes fussing about Europe, but guys with a proper,
if minor role now,
all they had to do was turn that minor role into the liberation of their entire
country. How hard could that be?
[Inaudible] the next few years.
Now like a globe trotting thriller master rig moved across Europe,
bouncing from France to Brisbane, to Russia,
always agitating for Czech and Slovak unity in a new state. Yup.
Czech and Slovak in 1915,
XLS from both communities had started making plans for a Federation and master
Rick had picked up that ball and just run with it.
And it was really running massive.
Rick was convinced Austrian agents were trying to assassinate him as he hopped
around Europe. And he even told Ben Ash to use his death for propaganda.
Should he be killed? Speaking of propaganda, master Rick was a deft handed it,
making sure article's sympathetic to the check cause appear daily in allied
newspapers. When the saw was overthrown in 1917,
even traveled to Russia to organize former Czech and Slovak POW's into a theist
fighting unit.
These Czechoslovak Legionnaires would run remnants in Russia for years at one
point even controlling the Trans-Siberian railway.
And so it went massive zooming around the globe,
shoring up support for Czechoslovak independence with each new destination.
His fame grew with each new PR stunts, a few more came over to his cause,
but it would be in the U S that master Eric, Matt,
his greatest convert Woodrow Wilson was almost the perfect match for master X
left-leaning independence minded politics at the head of America's Jack and
Slovak. Group's master it compressed his goals onto the 28 presidents.
And it clearly works on January the eighth, 1918 Wilson listed his 14 points,
including the complete dismemberment of Austria Hungary.
A couple of months later,
the Lansing declaration explicitly gave us backing to an independent
Czechoslovakia from Iran.
Aus events took on an air of inevitability in may master recognize with
Slovak representatives in Pittsburgh,
where the two sides struck and agreements on Slovak autonomy within the new
state in June,
the allies declared the still non-existent Czechoslovakia and allies power and
recognize the borders proposed by massive wreck.
But despite the feeling in the app was nothing inevitable about any of this
historical events feel inevitable because we're looking back on them as if they
were as unchangeable then as they are now.
But the reality is that none of this was set. Austria.
Hungary could have easily survived the war in tags,
or maybe the chat glands of Bohemia and Moravia could have broken off,
but left the Slovak. So persecuted minority in Hungary,
the fact cause of Akea ever existed is down almost entirely.
It's a master ex tireless work. Finally on October the 28th of 1918,
this new nation officially broke off from the collapsing empire by now massive
breakage.
It's already been named president of the interim governments and hastily made
arrangements to our sands of Prague.
His original plan was to meet in a cafe with some old friends and celebrate.
The new Republic bus. As he got closer.
To Europe, it became clear that he wasn't returning to his cozy old life.
Wasn't even returning as TG. Masaryk the new interim presidents.
He was returning as the father of an entire nation on December the 21st
master, Rick arrived to vast crowds, desperate to catch a glimpse of him.
The next day, he stood at Prague causal and proudly declared.
The affairs of your governments are returned into your hands once more, Oh,
check people and therein lay the problem.
Massive Rick may have left Prague Czech nationalists,
but had returned leader of a country in which checks just barely made up a
majority in this brave new land. A sixth of the population was Slovak.
Almost a quarter were German.
And there were significant minorities of Hungarians poles and resilience.
If master Rick wanted to make Czechoslovakia work,
he was going to have to convince all these wildly different groups that the
government spoke for them. Spoiler that here, it never quite succeeded.
The seeds.
He is undoing was sown almost the moment it was created in February, 1920,
a constitutional assembly was called to determine the shape of this new state,
but only Czechs and Slovaks were invited that left a third of the nation
citizens without a say,
and that country would be run where the Germans work in Sans.
This would soon turn out to be a massive problem.
We did a whole video on the Sudeten Germans over on the geographics channel.
If you want to learn more about that.
But the basic version is that Germans had been living in Bohemia and Moravia for
centuries as an ethnic group.
They were far more numerous than the Slovaks and had no interest in taking part
in a stage run specifically for their Slavic neighbors. No,
they wanted the same freedoms mastery had fought for and won from the Austrians,
the right to succeed and to control their own destiny.
But now that the shoe was on the other foot master, it was suddenly all like,
no. And nor was it just the Germans who were unhappy in America,
master Rick promised the Slovak something akin to home rule. Indeed.
He personally envisioned a Swiss star system with each group,
basically left to do their own thing.
But the reality of leading a brand new unstable state soon destroyed this
idealism as the 1920s grabbed onwards Paolo was centralized more and more in
Prague as more and more in the hands of Masaryk.
Although he wielded no formal power as president master,
Rick had a big enough reputation,
enough charming enough allies in politics and the media to get his way on
almost every issue.
There is always something known as castle politics with a small clique centered
around Masaryk effectively ruling outside parliament,
no matter how often Masaryk made speeches promising a federal system in the
future.
The reality was that Czechoslovakia was becoming a highly centralized oligarchy.
Yes, if it was really an oligarchy, it was a fundamentally liberal one,
a diehard liberal at heart.
Masaryk genuinely believed in respecting the rights of all of his subjects,
even separatists like the sea date and Germans or Hungarians,
the constitution guaranteed their freedom of speech, language, worship,
and assembly, a repressive place. This certainly wasn't master.
Rick also went out of his way to try and modify the unhappier ethnicities and
1925 with Germany to recognize one another's borders as legitimate when it's a
long way towards getting the Sudeten Germans on site. In fact,
by the time Masaryk was reelected in 1927, that was good reason to be hopeful.
The economy was booming.
A massive road and rail building plan was keeping people in workings.
A treaty had been reached with France to offer the Republic a security guarantee
on the 10th anniversary of Czechoslovakia.
His foundation master even felt comfortable enough to declare.
We began with empty hands without an army without constitutional traditions,
with a rapidly failing currency in the midst of economic chaos.
And yet we have stood the test and acquitted ourselves with honor.
There was an optimism in the app, a feeling that things were bumpy now,
but with time and a little luck that smoothed out and Czechoslovakia would take
its rightful place among the great democracies. Unfortunately,
time and luck were both things in short supply in 1928,
master X suffered a massive heart attack.
Although he survived the shock to his system, left him a physical wreck,
weak and broken.
It was the perfect metaphor for what was about to happen to both Czechoslovakia
and the entire world. As the end of the decade, came into view.
A massive shock was approaching one that would leave central Europe desperately
sick. It was a sickness, a terrible poison,
a sickness called fascism that would finally kill masseur Axiom.
Country.
29Th,
1929 wall street fell to earth with a crash heard around the globe.
It was the start of the great depression,
a decade of misery unemployment and endless gnawing hunger in Czechoslovakia.
It blew through industrial cities like a bitter wind shuttering towns
leaving millions destitute. Unfortunately,
most of the worst cities were in the sedate and lands as Prague launched a
modest relief program.
The sedate in Germans watched as their livelihoods were destroyed.
Undoubtedly Jackson Slovak suffered in the depression,
but reality isn't what matters.
What matters is that the German minority began to feel like [inaudible] didn't
care about them.
The Prague was looking out only for Slavs and leaving the Germans to suffer.
So when a silly little man with a funny mustache to power in Germany,
proper promising to make the Germans great again. Well, it,
isn't hard to see how the Sudeten Germans dreams of succession might come
roaring back the rise of the Sudeten and fascist party under hit the fan. Boy,
Conrad handline coincided with a deterioration in master X health.
Although he was reelected again in 1934,
it was mainly because no other viable candidates existed.
Mastery could succeeded in identifying himself with the state so much that
nobody could conceive of a time without him, but that time was almost upon them.
In may of 1935,
parliamentary elections returned 44 seats for headlines fascists, a single seat,
less than the largest party with over two thirds of all sedation Germans.
Now backing a succession as party.
It was clear Czechoslovakia wasn't going hold together much longer.
Masseur X though, wouldn't live to see the better ends on December the 14th,
1935 master Rick abruptly resigned passing the presidency to his old buddy
at VOD banish.
Then the father of the nation slipped away into retirement to wait the
inevitable for nearly two more years,
master at clung to life clung on just as Czechoslovakia did,
even as the sickness grew inside it.
So many people who came to inquire about his health assistant started hanging
posters on the gate every morning, giving updates on the situation.
Finally on September the 14th,
1937 came the poster baring the worst updatable DG masseur
record died that day aged 87. When his funeral was held a week later,
it lasted nine whole hours.
Such was the volume of people who wanted to pay tribute almost exactly a year
after MasTec was buried. France, Britain,
Italy in Germany signed the Munich agreements,
allowing Hitler to annex the Sudeten lands.
It was the beginning of a painful death for Czechoslovakia its border regions
lost to Germany. The young country was forced to simply lie.
There is first Poland and then hungry Tor yet, or chunks out of it.
Leaving a weak rump state, barely clinging to life in March of 1939,
Germany delivered the fatal blow Bohemia and Moravia were occupied well.
So the Ikea was split off into a separate state under a fascist puppet
government. Yet the story didn't end that despite its Rocky life,
the Czech and Slovak Republic established by master egg proved durable enough
that when world war two finally ended, it didn't stay broken and partitions.
It was resurrected nearly whole.
The new Czechoslovakia then lasted another 48 years surviving a communist
takeover and decades of dictatorship before peacefully separating into the
modern day Czech Republic and Slovakia in 1993.
But what of Tomasz Masaryk himself? Well,
he's still regarded as a hero in many places, not least here in Prague,
and it's not hard to see why he was a man who didn't just lead his nation,
but he was the sole reason for its existence before mastering the idea of an
independent Czech and Slovak nation away from Austria.
Chile embrace had been a pipe dream.
It was he who took that dream and forced it into reality,
shaping the future through the sheer force of his vision.
And that vision is why master it is still important as someone unafraid to stand
up for the truth for the downtrodden master rig brought a solely needed humanism
to politics. One reflected in the tolerant state that he built short.
He may not have truly achieved it because he never lost sight of his goal to
build a nation in which all ethnicities could live the best lives. They could.
His name may be obscure compared to some of his contemporaries,
but there's no doubt that master Eric helps shapes not just central Europe's
past, but also its present. The man himself may be long gone,
but his dream lifts on. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe brand new videos just like this several times a week
and as always, thank you.
[Inaudible].